Hello, everybody!
I wanna congratulate the American Cancer Society and everyone...
...who's taking part in this year's Great American Smokeout.
Over the years, we've made great progress in reducing the number of Americans who smoke.
But today, 46 million Americans are still hooked,...
...and tobacco remains the leading cause of preventable early deaths in this country.
Fact is, quitting smoking is hard.
Believe me, I know.
But we can make it easier,...
...which is why we have resources available through the Department of Health and Human Services...
...at HHS.gov to help more Americans put down cigarettes for good.
We also know that the best way to prevent the health problems that come with smoking,...
...is to keep young people from starting in the first place.
That's why in 2009, I was proud to sign the Family Smoking Prevention and Tobacco Control Act...
...which gives us new tools to keep cigarettes out of the hands of our kids,..
...including new warning labels that make sure that anyone who buys a pack of cigarettes is aware of the risk.
Today, some big tobacco companies are trying to block these labels...
...because they don't wanna be honest about the consequences of using their products.
Unfortunately, this isn't surprising.
We've always known that the fight to stop smoking in this country won't be easy,...
...but it's people like all of you who make me confident that together...
...we can help Americans everywhere live longer, happier, and healthier lives.